president biden administration on monday
ordered ordered departments to change
the terms
used to describe immigrant immigration
matters including how to refer to those
who entered the country
illegally the administration order came
in the form of memos can you pull up the
storycast so
people can see it memos sent to leaders
of immigration of
custom enforcement which is ice and
custom and border protection which is
cbp
alien will now be non-citizen or migrant
alien age
will be changed to non-citizenship
unaccompanied alien children will be
non-citizen
unaccompanied children this is this by
the way this is not a joke and this is
not april fools
unaccompanied alien and illegal alien
will be undocumented non-citizens
undocumented individual or
immigrant migrant and assimilation
will be integration or civil integration
immigrant assimilation will be immigrant
integration notably federal
law referrals to an area refers to an
alien as
any person not a citizen or national of
the united states
federal law also refers to the term
illegal aliens john you can take it from
here
well if at least they push integration
instead of assimilation but i don't know
what's wrong with assimilation
i can see the reasoning for the first
part to call someone an
alien is a little bit like
calling them like someone from outer
space and it
makes it maybe harder for them to
assimilate in america
the sad part is that fox news is running
this
and cnn and ms won't touch it i
assume they won't touch it they
certainly won't
display it prominently and there's just
two different worlds we live in now
keep going down what are you looking for
federal law refers to an alien as any
person not a citizen on the national
united states federal laws refers to
them as
illegal aliens so this was actually
pretty interesting to me because
you know they're basically saying like
look let's not call people aliens let's
not
call people you know alienage anything
with an alien you know shout out to elon
musk we know what he likes to do with
aliens
assimilation but then you kind of keep
reading down and it says what is elon
musk like to do with
i think he likes to have sex with aliens
that's just my opinion and he's turning
his girlfriend into an alien his baby
mama
as a libertarian he doesn't care just so
you know you're cool he does not give a
flying no he doesn't you okay you okay
i'm okay if aliens want to have sex with
us
[Laughter]
it's mutual take ufos
okay well kai could you pull that back
up thanks buddy
says federal law refers to an alien as
any person not a citizen or a national
united states
federal law often refers to them as a
legal alien so this is federal law
okay so part of me there's two sides of
this there's part of me that's
you know joe biden whether you like him
or not part of the reason he got
elected was because he had empathy that
was like a big
term that was thrown around with with
biden i know pat may disagree
but you know biden one of his highest
qualities or traits approval rating wise
was empathy so what he's trying to do is
humanize these people they're not aliens
they're not
you know non-human but then you kind of
keep reading and it's like well
actually federal law actually refers to
them as aliens so
this is sort of the pc police taking
over and
i'm okay with not calling them an alien
and calling them a non-citizen that's
fine but
you know it's it's uh oh my gosh river
here we go
are you and haley are you freaking
kidding me what are we
talking about on one here i'm i agree
with adam on this one
you're talking about us being
uncomfortable with your words
so let me ask you what do you think
about the the washington football team
do you agree with changing the names
no that why not that's offensive
redskins that's
it to whom that's the point what's
offensive about illegal aliens
to whom well that's different it
suggests you're from outer space
illegal aliens which is what the federal
terminology has been used for decades
now it's
saying that i'm out of space when aliens
do come here from outer space what do we
call them
non-citizens we gotta use the correct
they're the the aliens
sure okay okay these are illegal
citizens illegal aliens
okay oh my gosh were you an illegal
alien
they call me fresh off the boat and i'm
a great swimmer
but you flew here i flew here i know but
what i'm saying to you is i really could
care less
well you have thicker skin than it's not
about having thicker well you do no it's
not the point but the point is we need
we need to help people have thicker skin
okay this is an ugly world
are you kidding me like i have to teach
my kids to be ready for when they post a
picture on instagram that people are
gonna say you look like and you
gotta be okay with it
not the other way around are you
flipping kidding me like we're gonna sit
here and be like
hey you offended somebody shut the hell
up
we're being offended non-stop my kid's
being offended every damn day he goes to
school what do i tell him
hey that kid offended you poor you no
it's gonna happen
it's inevitable they're gonna make fun
of his stuttering just like they made
fun of me being 61135
they call me a somalian when i was 13
years old for two years that was my
nickname you may laugh at it right now
because i was the skinniest kid on
campus oh wow i was 61135
we grew up with nicknames what was your
nickname did you have one or you're like
perfectly you want to tell us your
nickname or no i was slick
you were slick i was like you know
moving and grooving did you have a
nickname with your was there a nickname
with your pops was your nickname with
your
father all i'm saying i'm not saying you
know you need to say the point is
we all had something true so what are we
going to do hey stuttering
hey you're basically saying we need to
develop thicker skin it's not about that
it's about the fact that leave
it alone oh my gosh every other word is
offending somebody today and we're all
becoming little pansies
look people call me out all the time
they'll say stuff i disagree with your
business model you have the right to
disagree
i disagree with your political stance
you have the right to disagree with me
i disagree with the fact that you
believe capitalism is good i'm totally
okay with that
i disagree with the fact that you're a
christian how could somebody like you
that's read so many books believe in a
god
how could you believe in a god i agree
with you wanting to debate me on that
and disagree with that it's totally fine
but to sit there and say hey uh you
can't offend me because it's unfair to
say this it's not fair to say that
i'm sorry man we're just breeding soft
little pansies who are extremely
sensitive
with words because the next person comes
on that says this is offensive
just so you know every time they do this
you know what happens there's 300 other
people that are coming out and saying
this is also offensive
that's also offensive this is also
offensive that's also offensive you know
what happens the next 10 years
no one wants to say anything you don't
want to say so imagine you're going
out there flirting so give me some lines
on how we floated when the camera was on
on us
give me some of the dumbest lines we
ever used that people would be concerned
about using it today
dumbest lines you want to give the lines
or you don't want to share something i
can't remember my tricks
the point i'm trying to make the best
line ever maybe in the history of lions
was from joey from friends how you doing
that's the best that's the best lineup
yeah
what i'm trying to tell you what i'm
trying to tell you is men are afraid to
flirt with girls because what if it's a
little bit too
you know the hands i don't think guys
are afraid to fly oh buddy the guy from
superman said i'm afraid of wooing
people and girls and kind of courting
them because you're talking about
well you're also talking about uh keanu
reeves he does his picture yeah it's and
by the way what is that all about like
the lower back thing you got to go four
inches above the lower back
five two inches below the bra like if i
touch the bra oh my gosh should i offend
you like what do i do it's like
there's like 75 million regulations
today on how to do it right everybody's
walking on eggshells you must take a lot
of pictures eventually
do you have rules to that john stossel
has an only fans account
what somehow i knew what to do
posing for those pictures it was never
an issue
and somehow even though i had young
interns
harvey weinstein said well at the time
it was just accepted
that's a different story it was
i always knew i couldn't sleep with the
interns until they were no longer
interns
okay john there you go but here's the
point though there is
the uh uh bernie madoff which is
qualified you saw what his son said
before he committed a suicide the note
and some people say it didn't happen
whether it did it or not
the fact that the son committed suicide
in 2008 after what happened that's a
tragic event i don't want to see
anybody's son wanting to do that it's
the
most painful thing a parent is going to
go through the next one you're talking
about
uh with the guy right here who's the guy
right here in palm beach who
got caught a year and a half ago epstein
epstein and julian maxwell
right okay that guy you know he
he dirty whatever you can qualify him
any way you want
but i'm not talking extreme we're not
talking extreme
award is offensive today oh mike by the
way
is the f-bomb offensive to a lot of
people yes okay
you think we're desensitized to the word
today i think it's because yes
yes i agree you know what also
desensitized today drop warts today
that don't have the weight they carry 20
years ago racist
everyone's racist today bigot okay what
else you want to add to the list
what else would you say the f-bomb is a
normal
social media influencers today i saw a
guy
going up there giving dropping the
f-bomb left and i'm like dude it doesn't
fit you
it's just not you okay but now it's like
you have to do it because it's cool
it's okay so what if the f-bombs are
fencing people somebody comes out and
says let's stop using the word f-bomb no
keep using it oh i have the word
i have the word what's that public
figure you can put on your damn profile
that you're a public figure you can have
like it's not
400 yeah but it's not even back in the
day if you're a public figure you're a
movie star you're a politician
you're a freaking john stossel you're a
public figure sure now
the hoe down the block's a public figure
i'm sorry yeah okay
i said it watch your language but again
i'm not offended
it's words okay are you easily offended
these days or
you got thick skin you know barbara
walters used to say
i never read my negative mail
or my mail because i can't stand the
negative ones
and now i go on facebook and twitter and
when people
when smart sounding people say mean
stuff yes i'm still that thin-skinned
can you still bothers you i think about
this by the way i think it's good
okay but meaning i think it's good if it
still bothers us you care
no buddy it bothers who's the toughest
person that words don't bother give me a
person that you think
in the world donald trump i disagree i
think it bothers him the most
i think he's very sensitive i think it
bothers him more than it bothers you
i think it bothers him so much more that
he wants to do more to retaliate and you
don't want to do as much to retaliate
so who is the person that's not offended
by words hmm
give me one name i think obama is pretty
uh i disagree
if i disagree because if obama was he
would have gone to fox news more often i
think obama also
he didn't want to meet with paul ryan
too often because paul ryan would say
bernie sanders
i think he's got a pretty damn thick
skin i would actually say bernie sanders
may have thick skin
but i also think he's also sensitive
what's the point here
buddy if you got a pulse we're all we're
all sensitive the barometer is just
maybe a little bit higher a little bit
lower you know you know how they say
never offend the wrong person because
they may come back and
you know come after you for decades the
most sensitive people you offend
they're going to come for a long time
right but for the most part we all get
offended by
it's going to hurt you no matter what
and two points about that we only get to
the truth
via debate and if you can't debate
vigorously you don't get to the truth
and the other point is you mention
bernie madoff and you defend capitalism
it's a good example of why capitalism is
good
that bernie madoff and enron people cite
that is look at these greedy cat look at
all the people who got ripped off
what's remarkable in our 15 trillion
dollar economy
is that they're front-page news it shows
how
rare that is the big scam
today with free information so that's
another word by the way the word scam
everyone's dropping it that it
used to be easy to scam people because
people wouldn't find out
now you instantly get a bad internet
reputation yeah
and so if you don't serve your customer
better than the other guys
you're gone i think it's the fairest
thing out there
i think competition is the fairest thing
out there to allow people to compete for
the market share so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch
or if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
you